the Supreme Court has ruled in the case
of the Baker who refused to bake a gay
wedding cake and they have ruled in
favor of the Baker but as usual the
truth of the decision is being sort of
misrepresented in media reports it was a
7-2 ruling you saw two liberal justices
join the five conservative justices and
to remind you about the story this is
about a Colorado Baker who refused to
bake a gay wedding cake for what they
called religious reasons and this was a
decision before we got it from the
Supreme Court that had the potential to
really set precedent for letting people
say they are exempt from
non-discrimination laws because their
religious beliefs contradict some of
those laws and of course it would follow
that if you can be exempt from
non-discrimination laws on the basis of
sexual orientation why couldn't your
religious beliefs also exempt you from
race-based
non-discrimination laws potentially very
dangerous but the court if you read the
actual decision rather than the
headlines from yesterday's in today's
articles the court didn't actually say
when there can be exemptions to
non-discrimination laws for religious
reasons let me say that one more time
the Court did not decide about
exemptions to anti-discrimination laws
what the Court did say is that the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission when
they adjudicated this case and said the
Baker violated the anti-discrimination
law showed impermissible hostility okay
so if people are going to hear about
this and say great all Baker's and other
service providers now can just flout
anti-discrimination laws and say I don't
work with gay customers or I don't work
with black customers because of my
religion they could quickly find
themselves in trouble because that's not
what the court said okay the real
question that the court did not answer
is whether baking a cake is the type of
act that's protected by the First
Amendment by free speech that's the real
question
and the court did not actually answer
that in their ruling all they said is
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission
that originally adjudicated this was
hostile to the religion of
the baker in a way that was not okay
they weren't neutral on religion when
deciding the case that is very different
than saying you can cite religion as a
reason to legally ignore
non-discrimination laws really important
path that people understand what the
Court did decide and what it did not
decide yeah that's why they're calling
this a narrow decision some people read
the headlines and were confused because
it's a narrow decision and yet they
voted seven to two or more Donald Trump
jr. took to Twitter and was very
confused over this it just applies in
this specific case you can't make any
broader implications from it like you
could from 2015 gay marriage decision
its roots in sports gambling decision
and even the plaintiffs in the case
conceded it actually wouldn't be okay
for a Baker to refuse to sell anything
for gay weddings that that would
actually be a different story altogether
it is specifically because the cake
baking is possibly an artistic endeavor
and because of the treatment from the
Colorado Civil Rights Commission that
the decision went this way this has not
changed what it is at least for now
which is that businesses that are open
to the public have to serve everybody
regardless of race regardless of
national origin or nationality religion
sexual orientation in some states is
also a protected class in that vein I
believe that there will be blowback from
people misunderstanding this ruling and
openly discriminating and they will very
quickly find themselves on the other
side of court decisions because the
issue here is that of the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission according to the
Supreme Court ruling it's not a great
decision I'm not saying that I like the
results but what I think is most
important to understand is this is not
the terrible news for LGBT people that
some are painting it out to be I'm not
saying I agree with it but it's
important not to do the sky is falling
stuff because of this particular
decision because it is a very narrow
decision about the specific way in which
this one case was handled it is not
carte blanche to start saying we don't
serve gay people we don't serve black
people we don't serve Jewish people or
anything of that nature send me your
thoughts I want to hear from you about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's episode of the show is
made possible in part by Kronecker
wallace which is a small independent
book publisher with a passion for both
the history of science and the actual
visual design of books Kronecker wallace
has been attracting a lot of attention
for their reissues of iconic scientific
works like for example Isaac Newton's
Principia Euclid's elements and a
beautiful collection of over 300
drawings by prominent 19th century
scientist alexander von humboldt from
throughout his world travels Kronecker
Wallace's motto is books are something
to touch and look at not just read I can
get behind that people in the audience
know what sets Kronecker Wallace apart
from other publishers of historical
scientific books as their dedication to
craftsmanship and designing books that
are also actually stunning from a visual
aesthetic perspective and these are for
people who love science but also for
people who love books themselves and
appreciate the art of book making you
want to check out their collection for
yourself at Kronecker Wallace comm
that's K ro n
waa ll you also have until midnight
Eastern on June 6 to pre-order their
reissue of Isaac Newton's optics on
Kickstarter I've put a link to that and
their main website underneath this video
if you're watching on YouTube